Clark Kellogg Turner CBS Westwood one
NCAA analyst joining us back here in the
program how you been Clark I'm terrific
rich great to visit with you how are you
doing
sounds like you're in good form well you
know what I just get excited seeing
performances like that even though it
destroyed my bracket just seeing
performances like that in games like
that last night was what's the hottest
shootin night you ever had do you ever
have a Ryan Klein type night Clark I
think I made a couple I had one in
school actually my senior year I recall
was opening night and we were expected
to be really good and I was really
excited about getting the season going
and you know it's amazing kind of what
stays on the harddrive
your mind this is you know 40 years ago
ready and I can remember distinctly make
22 out of 26 or 20 and all variety of
shots no floaters jumpers I mean it was
just one of those nights men they don't
come along a bunch but when they do they
kind of stick in your memory and that
was amazing
I mean the step-back three to tie the
game at 80 that we just repaired right
there - Clark how dangerous is Purdue do
you think in the long run here extremely
I mean when you think about the ability
to make threes at that will he in Carson
that wears both in a net which is a
dynamic score because of his ability to
move with the ball shoot it off the
dribble drive to the goal he was
uncharacteristically poor from the foul
line that was the only issue with that
game I mean there were 31 missed
free-throws between the teams rich
otherwise I mean they both shot 50% plus
from the floor made 27 threes between
them on 55 attempts and low turnover
games so then the missed free throws
which actually added to some of the
drama and excitement quite honestly as
we went to the extra session but it was
a really exciting game to come back from
18 down the three-point shoot and I
think there was a time in that game and
I'd have to go back and watch it but I
think seven or eight baskets in a row
that were made that's right four threes
between the two teams I mean at most
gold-filled lamonta turn
on the Tennessee side and then obviously
Klein was in another zone I mean here 22
and then he made seven of 10 told her
but it was really fantastic to watch how
those teams went at it down the stretch
do you think Carson Edwards was in fact
a foul in the corner for three do I do
the initial look at it head on to Carson
I thought lamonta had done a nice job of
challenging without fouling but when you
got the baseline look he actually did
bump him in the mid area lower body and
you've got to protect the shooter
according to how the rules are written a
tough tough call and it's not ideal
you'd love to see it just be a play on
but that contact warranted the whistle
according to how the rule is written so
I had no problem with it after um after
seeing as a second time well I was
watching that on the big screen that
they had up in the Honda Center in
Anaheim in between the games between
Gonzaga's went over Florida State and
and Texas Tech's demolishing of Michigan
and it was easily the most excited the
crowd had gotten all night even with all
everyone of every fanbase had got me and
everyone was just hanging on it and
every moment and and part of that is
because you know after that game was
finished up Texas Tech just took all the
air out of Michigan and the Texas Tech
fans that were there last night I will
never forget that experience
what does Texas Tech do better on
defense than then everyone else because
they are the best defensive team left in
this tournament if not the entire
country
yeah all year rich and what they do is
they're really committed to their scheme
they're very sound and they can defend
the ball individually really well when
you look at Jared Culver and Matt Mooney
and Moretti you watch them they don't
get beat a lot one-on-one and when they
do guard the ball one-on-one the other
guys are in their gaps and really really
tied together well and then you got shot
blocking presents with tarik Owens one
of the very best shot blockers in the
country you've got physicality with ot
hace so you've got all of the elements
and then a great commitment to it skin
from all of the players and obviously
you've got to give the coaching staff
great credit but they don't get beat
they can guard their their man
individually really well and then you
combine that with good team schematics
and a good team awareness and they just
don't give you much easy and they turn
the water off on the Wolverines in a big
way last night yeah I mean when you say
don't give her anything easy every time
Texas Tech turned the ball over and it
was a transition three guys were back I
mean there was a single opportunity it
was it was it was mauling it was an
absolute mauling how how much of an
opportunity you think Texas Tech has to
cut down the nets
well they do because they defended such
a high level and they found some good
rhythm offensively here in the last few
weeks
other than the game against West
Virginia they lost in the big 12
tournament they had been playing really
well offensively and you combine those
two things ever travel wherever you go
Gonzaga showed an awful lot at the
defensive end last night and have shown
at all season it got away from them for
a time in that st. Mary's game but other
than that they've been really found
defensively and they were outstanding
defensively last night the Bulldogs I
give the Bulldogs the edge because
they've been much more consistent and
the nation's best offensive team all
season long you combine that with the
grit they showed offensively last night
and on the glass I think they'll find a
way to get enough points or to create a
cushion to be able to really make it
hard for Texas Tech to come back on them
but if Texas Tech jumps out and gets a
good lead early on and then they play
through culver it could be problematic
but I like the Zags to win just because
of their overall offensive balance Clark
Kellogg here on the Rich Eisen show so
are we still just all rent payers in
Dukes world or or UCS I was never in
that camp
I mean I'm enjoying the ride and
obviously the phenomenon of Zion
Williamson is really special it doesn't
come along like that very often when you
see a player that is the first of his
kind that we've seen I mean we've had
periods and players but it's usually
every 20 years
so and I go back to probably Shaq in
terms of a player that had you
scratching your head who was he like
because he's really unique and jaian as
much that way oscar robertson was that
way will was that way kareem was that
way magic was that way Pistol Pete in
another type of way was that way again a
roast those are some serious legs Clark
Clark those are serious names those are
some serious names I'm not talking about
in terms of career I'm talking about in
terms of unique appearance on the scene
and production and how they did it I
mean you think about his speed his size
his agility his IQ and savvy has
impacted both ends you can only count
those kind of players on maybe two hands
and your feet when you talk about really
unique impactful players that maybe set
a trend for that kind of player going
forward LeBron would be in that category
and so again I think he's that type of
unique presence and then you factor in
his charisma where he's playing how he's
playing all of that lends to what has
become really a must-see television for
those that are interested in basketball
and unique stories and his first two
performances statistically as good as
Durant's that's the last time we saw
somebody you want to keep throwing names
out there from the tournament but that
talent in the hands of Coach K who also
has guys like reddish and obviously
Barrett at his disposal we're not we're
not paying rent and Dukes were you so
who do you who do you like for me no no
I don't think so I mean clearly I
believe they should be the favorite but
I don't think it's a foregone conclusion
that they automatically win it the one
thing that gives me some pause rich is
youth and anytime you're talking about
winning championships it's very rare
that teams even if they're supremely
talented but lack some experience are
able to get it done in a six-game run to
a championship the tooth
fifteen Duke team obviously was carried
by freshmen but there were some key
seniors on that team as well if I'm not
mistaken Quinn cook Jefferson so you've
got to have some of that because in the
crucible of the one-and-done format
teams can game plan against you and part
of what happened against UCF is that
Duke was able to make threes but UCF did
keep them out of transition for the most
part and made them go over the top as
opposed to through them and to Duke's
credit RJ Barrett and Zion and cam and
even trade Jones made a key bucket they
were able to rise to the occasion and
we'll see if they can continue to do
that because I think Virginia Tech
they're number one and fewest points
allowed in the paint in the country
Virginia Tech is this pack of size eight
job of packing it in and make team
making teams over the top and we'll see
if Duke is able to do that even with his
eye on the last meeting Virginia Tech
didn't have to face ion couple more
minutes left with Clark Kellogg who is a
final four studio analyst CBS and Turner
right here on the show so are you
sitting next to Charles watching the
Auburn Carolina game tonight are you in
his presence from might have to be it I
might have to be a volunteer official
between in and key and Canada and I
don't have to separate those guys okay
actually preparing to do that in some
form or fashion and I imagine it would
get pretty young pretty intense with
those Tigers and Tar Heels I'm going at
it for an opportunity to get to the
Elite Eight it should be great fun
though I'm sure what is that like can
you take a fan in what's it like sitting
with Charles and obviously canning for
for their for their because we all love
basketball there's tremendous mutual
respect we've got a great team when you
factor in Wally who has been in there
with a Szczerbiak Greg Gumbel and Ernie
Johnson last week and the folks you
don't see but just those two guys are
really they're authentic they're genuine
they're good guys they love hoops and
they're funny so it's a it's a really
good time to enjoy some laughs while
we're talking about college basketball
so but you have to get in between them
essentially at some point
I think I might I think I might because
it's all now you know all of the talk
leading up to it rich is fun and games
but the real deal happens tonight and
one of those teams is moving on to the
Elite Eight and I think is alarms of
those schools I know how I would feel
and half felt when the Buckeyes have
been in that position in basketball
football or other sports it's part of
where your heart is yeah you talk about
your alma mater having success so I know
to be pretty I'm pretty intense and
emotional in there for those guys
tonight yeah we don't talk oh how state
football around here Clark we just
glossed hard and we gloss my mind on
occasion because of being so attached to
that place and I still live in Columbus
so it's I'm not too far from my mind and
my tongue great spot it really is I
obviously just haven't just having fun
so with Houston and Kentucky how does
that match up tonight before I let you
go here a big question mark is PJ
Washington's availability and even if he
can play what level of effectiveness
will he have I think Houston is one of
the more undervalued and
underappreciated teams in the country
they don't do it with great flash but
they do play top-shelf defense I think
in defensive efficiency when you look at
some of the sabermetrics they may be
number one in the country overall in
defensive efficiency I think that's can
palms on statistical measure they
rebound at a high level they've got a
great shot maker and score and Corey
Davis jr. and although our money Brooks
has struggled in the tournament he's a
40% three-point shooter on the season
and very dangerous and they got a number
of good young players that I think are
competitive that are not afraid and that
really relished this opportunity to
surprise the world I actually picked
them to go to the Final Four mm-hmm I'm
actually leaning towards Carolina coming
out of there now but I give Houston a
really good chance to prevail in
tonight's game so who do you
what did you have in your bracket before
I let you go here well I had two
brackets I did one on Selection Sunday
night on the air once we got done for
yes a selection show and that was three
number one seeds Duke well the three
number one sheet and then Houston okay I
kind of outlier I'd like to try to at
least have one team nurse maybe a little
bit off the radar and then I did another
one that was published on CBS sports.com
you know presented there and that was
Michigan State with Gonzaga Houston and
Virginia with Gonzaga winning it all in
both of the brackets because you you are
very much alive right now Clark Kellogg
on your brackets very last night was an
unmitigated disaster as Tennessee and
Michigan go out for me but that's just
me that's the beauty of this leg man
playing bracket I know that hey Clark
thanks the cult you have a great time
calling you're calling it on Westwood
won the final four and the national
champions look forward to that the last
few years I got my started radio way
back with the Pacers so it's kind of
back to the future and it's nice to have
a full full plate those two days at the
Final Four and you are with royalty with
John Thompson right next to you that is
Roy sir okay and then Bill Walton and
Jim Gray join us with the halftime show
know we got a great promenade are you
serious Jim Green Bill Walton together
take Jim on there on the deadhead tour
with them too that would be fantastic
be fantastic I love it and just does
John have the towel over his shoulder
for the for the Broadway sure he's got a
pretty good wit about him too nice sense
of humor so it's great fun really
appreciate the call thanks for the call
we'll chat soon yeah you got bets in
that's Clark Kellogg at Clark Kellogg
CBS on Twitter at C Longwood - geez CBS
on Instagram
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience
you